When you go for gender equity, what you want is, well, you want the facade,
right? You want 50, 50%, 50% here. And 50% there,
men and women, it doesn't matter if they're competent,
if they want to work there.
And we have government bodies regulating this and trying to, uh,
and we do this from kindergarten and upwards.
Can you talk about how this is related to sort of how men are treated or at
least talked about in Sweden because you guys have the first supposedly
self-proclaimed feminist government, right? Yes. Even though they are,
as you could tell, when they visited Iran, they all Wars niqab.
So very feminist indeed. Yeah. You're very fast. Um, but,
but the reason I mentioned that is because, uh, I, I, as I said earlier,
I did both of your podcasts,
which we'll link to below because I want people to see you guys as hosts.
But I mentioned the story to both of you, uh,
of how the day of the Stockholm shows it was cold out.
And I wanted to get a hat. And I went into H and M, which is your,
is that your greatest? Well, H and M gap here are your greatest exports. Um,
and I went into H and M and I was online to buy the hat and the guy in front of
me, young guy, probably 20, 21 years old says to the cashier, uh,
this is the first suit I've ever bought. Uh, he was speaking in English,
the first suit I've ever bought. And, uh,
and I'm going to see this Jordan Peterson show tonight.
And then the cashier says, I'm going to see the Jordan beaters and Joe tonight.
So I tapped the guy on the shoulder. I turned around. I said,
I'm going to see the Jordan beaters that Joe. And he knew who I was.
And I just thought it was such an incredible moment like this young kid who
literally was buying the first suit of his life to, as you just said,
listen to a Canadian psychology professor,
tell him to sit up straight with his shoulders back.
So can you talk a little bit about what's happening with either young people or
men or both, or some combination?
There's a problem with language because what I think they're trying to do in
Sweden have been trying for my entire life is they're trying to accomplish
gender equity.
And that's not the same thing as a quality of the sexes, right?
Have equality of the sexes in many senses, right?
It depends on what you mean with quality men and women have the same
opportunities. In some cases,
women even have more opportunities economically when it comes to subsidies for
being pregnant, for instance, or taking maternity leave.
The free choices that women make are though considered a problem. Because,
so this is the, this is the interesting way, but just to be clear though,
because what part of what I said, no, no, no. When, when you, uh,
when you go for gender equity, what you want is, well, you want the facade,
right? Do you want 50, 50%, 50% here? And 50% there,
men and women, it doesn't matter if they're competent,
if they want to work there.
And we have government bodies regulating this and trying to, uh,
and we do this from kindergarten and upwards, we, we, uh,
encourage the girls to take up more space and be less like girls.
And we encourage the boys to, you know,
close inwards and not take up as much pit space too.
So basically what they're trying to do is they're trying to make these kids go
against, uh, their biology or whatever they feel is right,
because they want it to look perfect. So to be clear,
it's not just equal justice, right? It's not just, um, you know,
you should act this way, but it ends up working into how, what jobs they choose.
Because, uh, Jordan mentioned this several times there,
and a lot of people talk about this, that you,
because you guys have had a quality for so long,
meaning you could do whatever you want as a man or a woman.
It turned out that yes,
women tend to be nurses more than men turn out to be engineers.
More because women generally are more interested in people.
And men happened to be more interested in things.
That's just the nature of reality,
but gender is what you were getting to the social justice warriors.
Don't like that experiment. They don't like the experiment.
Freedom. Jordan was on a talk show host in Sweden on a talk show in Sweden,
where he was addressing this very topic. And basically he said, well, you know,
science supports that this is the way it happens in a free country where people
can choose. And we had like one of the top level politicians there and she was,
well, I don't agree with that. And you know, I was just flat. I actually made a,
you know, an episode on my show about that,
because like this mind just society science says this, I don't agree with it.
Okay. So what, what are, you know, missing?
Yeah. But, but, so that thing though, so the,
the politician says that I don't agree with it.
I don't agree with what science says. I don't agree with what biology says.
We all know that men or women are different.
It doesn't make either sex better than the other. It just, it's just an is. Uh,
but when you hear that response,
you think most people just swallow that and take it.
I think most people do that because we're a fiercely egalitarian,
very conformist people.
So they have been drained for very long to just accept that form of
communication. Now we have, uh, you know, a government body,
the ministry of equality. And I mean,
just the name sounds like so totally Terry and I can't, you know,
it's like totally.
And they have the authority to look at like all companies and other
governmental bodies.
[Inaudible] schools, universities, everything,
everything has to be gender mainstream.
Run by women, the only women working at the so.
W right. So when you do this, then as a private businessman, how,
how does that affect you?
You know, funny thing is like, when I,
when my YouTube channel started taking off my business partner, he was like,
okay, what's happening. What's going on?
This might actually hurt our business interests. Uh, and I said, well, you know,
if we start seeing some, some, you know,
disasters happening because of what I'm saying online,
we'll have a conversation and say, okay, so we, we tried it for awhile.
Turns out business is booming because now people are there, you know,
finding me just because they see my videos. So I want to work for your company.
So even though we have all these enemies, now,
those are people wouldn't want to work with anyway.
Right. But what about on the hiring side though? I mean,
when you're actually hiring people, you have to look at that,
those immutable characteristics to figure out who you're going to hire.
Well, I don't handle the recruiting anymore personally.
So I've kind of removed myself my face from that a bit. Um,
I don't think it's much of a problem because Sweden has a general problem.
When it comes to recruiting talented people, we don't have enough of them.
We have a lot of people that are going, you know,
subsidies and various government programs, loads, but I mean, it recruiting,
you know, very smart it professionals. That's,
that's generally a very difficult,
although I find I have quite a few of them, you know,
these software guys that are quite libertarian,
so no, I don't see it. That's a great problem. The, you know, the,
here's another thing I'd like to mention.
You're not allowed to ask people anything you want when you hire them in Sweden.
So when I first started out with my company, I would ask people to,
are you in any unions began? I don't want any unionized people in my companies.
And then my HR, eventually you got to stop saying that Henrik it's illegal.
You cannot ask them if they're unionized. Um, so now we, we have a text.
And when we recruit, which is kind of like,
are you a very clear collectivistic minded person?
This might not be the place for you. Yeah.
Jeez. I mean, this is happening everywhere now.
So I think it does hurt kids because if you raise an entire
generations of girls telling them that they are beautiful and we can strong at
the same time and can do no wrong while you're turning them into sexist
fascists, basically.
And you're telling all the boys that they are inherently evil that's and we've
been doing this for a long time now.
So is that the part that's particularly perverse about this?
So you take a society, you make them equal then at the same time,
because you know that humans are going to have individual emotions. You keep,
you keep telling the males that they're evil,
despite the fact that you in Sweden have done more for equality than virtually
anybody. So it's, it's really like,
it's just never enough because actually as you guys know what they,
don't what they want. It's not really a quality it's no, no, yes. Convert. Yeah.
And I've been trying to tell them that this would be as if someone came out as
gay and you told them no, suppress that. Right.
Because that's what you're telling the boys like, Oh,
you feel the need to run around and play football, suppress it.
And in telling the girls like you're playing with dolls, bad girl,
go out and play football. Now, before the haters get in here and say, Oh,
Aaron flam doesn't want boys to play with Barbies.
You actually are perfectly okay. I never played football. I was not the type.
You have a huge Barbie collection, which for a man of your age is a bit much.
Now I was into He-Man and star Wars, figurines,
or action figures. Yes. You call them that to make them sound more manly,
but they're basically dolls. I'll show you my collection when we're out here.
Um, all right. Let's shift a little bit, because you mentioned actually that,
uh, lived in, I believe you're moving. If I can say that, um,
in Malmo now we hear a lot about Malmo on a certain side of the internet, uh,
where they report on a lot of bombings and stabbings and all these weird things
coming out of Malmo. Now we only hear of this from sort of right.
What I would say, not just center, right, but more right. Leaning things,
outlets in America.
And then anyone that reports on them says that they're racist and they're
bigoted and the rest of it. You live in mellow. What, what happened in Malmo?
And just tell me a little bit about the history of Malmo before anything else.
Mamo it's in the deep South of Sweden. Um, uh, so it's a port city. Uh,
this is where basically everyone that's coming to Sweden, you know,
by foot or by car,
that they will enter across a bridge and they come into Malmo.
So we have a very large, uh, number of, you know,
refugees and so forth from the crisis of 2015. And Malmo is,
is always been a rather poor city. And I used it. They used to big,
big ships there. And in the 1980s,
that old collapsed and everyone was an alcoholic for a while,
then it kind of came slightly better, but it's,
it's a loss-making city and it's,
it's been brung by socialist for better part of the last hundred years.
Now over time,
crime in MoMA started to rise uncontrolled.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about
international issues, instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our international playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.